million copies of 12 rules for life you
have 800 000 followers on twitter 1.4
million followers on youtube what is it
that you're selling that so many people
want to buy
i don't think i'm selling anything well
i went to a show where you were where
you were selling tickets to your show so
people are willing to pay a lot of money
to see you speak you know what is it
that you think that people are hungry
for they want to hear from you
they are hungry for a discussion of the
relationship between responsibility and
meaning
and we haven't had that discussion
in our culture for 50 years we've
concentrated on rights and privileges of
freedom and impulsive pleasure and those
are all useful in their place
but they're shallow and that's not good
because
if people are moored shallowly then
storms wreck them and storms come along
so i'm talking to people about how they
can
build a foundation underneath and that
works
and
and uh
people need to know that because
otherwise their lives are harder than
they need to be
what is it that you have that no one
else has what are you offering that no
one else is right now
well i think i think that is what i'm
offering
that's not part of the public discussion
you know and it's grounded okay
these interviewers from the last two
videos i don't know if they're listening
because
he literally just explained what he is
doing he's like what are you offering
that no one else says like
what
it's like they come in ready to hate him
yeah and it's like as an interviewer
you're not supposed
from my knowledge you're not supposed to
come in
with
already like trying to belittle someone
or
not hear them out you already have your
your
set
questions and you're already going after
them without listening to them it just
makes the interview
irritating because they're saying
something and you're saying
another thing
that doesn't even
go with what they're saying or you're
just not listening you ask them ask them
a question that they already said and
it's just like
yeah what are you doing you can tell
he's already so irritated yeah what he
said in the beginning he was like
i was
i was like okay jordan let her know
in my clinical knowledge
so i've been a clinician for a very long
time and i'm familiar with the works of
most of the great 20th century
clinicians and a reasonable amount of
philosophy and a good swath of
literature and
i'm a credible
scientist and so i can bring that all
together
and i've tried to bring it all together
and to make a case for
the significance of individual life and
the psychological necessity of courage
and nobility and
responsibility these things that sound
old-fashioned but
are old-fashioned in the best sense
they're old-fashioned because they've
lasted forever and they're absolutely
necessary
and people need a call to responsibility
because they need to mature they need to
want to be adults
you know and i don't think we do a very
good job in our culture of making a case
for why it's a good thing to be an adult
and two things really made you famous
which is first of all is the book twelve
rules for life the second one i think
was an interview that went viral with
kathy newman of of channel four news
which she talked about
men and women
right he's got a big big following but
that was i think really fascinating that
interview because it was specifically
about men and women and you said at the
time you know youtube sku's very male
and your fan base is very male is that
still the case are you still mostly
primarily talking to men um i would say
the talks are probably 60 40 65 35 male
to female
the book sales i don't know i doubt it
because usually it's women who buy books
although men do buy non-fiction if they
buy books we don't know the demographics
on the books
but the book has definitely expanded my
audience i would say
and that's a good thing as far as i'm
concerned i mean i never set out
specifically to talk to men my students
for most years at university have been
primarily female i was going to say that
i was thinking like i don't think he
specifically from what i've seen in
these last two videos that he like
specifically talks to
men it's just
the realm he's in is a very
male-dominated realm
and
women obviously women typically don't
listen to uh people in this sector but i
don't think he's gearing his stuff
straightly towards men like men men men
it's just the area that he's in well and
even if he was i don't understand why
that's a bad like they make it sound
like that's so bad like you're gearing
your stuff towards men if that's what he
wants to do that's what he wants to do
there's a lot of people that like grew
up without like in broken families or
without two parents
and so like like there's a lot of guys
that didn't have like a father figure to
look at so if it's him why is that such
a bad yeah exactly
just keep watching
i think most of my graduate students
have been female it might be about 50 50
but i think it would probably tilt more
in the direction of female so it wasn't
like it wasn't something i set out to do
i think though that as i said earlier
well i can't tell how much of it is
merely a consequence of the fact that
youtube skews so male
it might also be something to do with
the call to take on voluntary
responsibility
i'm not exactly sure why that would be
more necessary for men right now i think
it might be because our culture confuses
men's desire for achievement and
competence with the patriarchal desire
for tyrannical power and that's a big
mistake those aren't the same thing even
a bit
so and it's
very
inappropriate psychologically and
sociologically to confuse them
so well one of the things i want to come
back to is this idea so that you say in
the book you know there is masculine
order and feminine chaos yes no actually
i say that those are symbolic
representations of the two things right
okay so
why why is order masculine
um
i think it's because our primary
social hierarchy structures are
fundamentally masculine and that's not
the patriarchy
well
it's not the modern idea of the
patriarchy that's for sure i mean so
that's my idea of the patriarchy which
is a system of male dominance of society
yeah but that's not my sense of the
patriarchy so what's yours well in what
sense is our society male dominated
uh the fact that the vast majority of
wealth is owned by men the vast majority
of capital and is owned by men women do
more unpaid labor very tiny proportion
of men and a huge proportion of people
who are seriously disaffected are men
most people in prison are men
most people who are
on the street or men most victims of
violent crime are men most people who
commit suicide are men
most men most people who die in wars are
men people who do worse in school are
men it's like where's the dominance here
precisely what you're doing is you're
taking a tiny
substrata of hyper successful men and
using that to represent the entire
structure of the of western society
there's nothing about that that's
vaguely appropriate but i could say
equally what the most rape victims are
women terrible things happen to people
of both sexes and you could say that
with with perfect utility but that
doesn't provide any evidence for the
existence of a male-dominated patriarchy
well that just means the terrible things
happen to both genders which they
certainly do but there are almost no
women who rape men for example so that
is an asymmetry there in sexual violence
well yes there's an ace there's an
asymmetry in all sorts of places but
that doesn't mean that western culture
is a male-dominated patriarchy the fact
that there are asymmetries has nothing
to do with your basic argument no but
you
um
her statement first of all
she needs to know her facts and know how
to quote a book before she'd come he
said no this is what i actually said in
the book it's like okay
tumbled she was humble real quick he
said actually no this is what it's in
there she's like oh i say tell her let
her know
but
her her statement on
um
grape and the
with
men
and
women and men i don't think that
there i don't think that it's not
happening i just think that
men don't say anything
from
what
what i've heard in different situations
men don't say anything because it's like
oh you let a woman do that to you how do
you do that why don't you overpower her
from my knowledge and
i don't think that is
a valid
um
stat to give in what he's saying and
everything well and
i have heard a lot of stories about
young guys getting taken advantage of
from like cougars or like middle-aged
moms or it was like my friend's mom made
a move on me
and we're just not in a society where
like
it's common for men to come forward
about about that stuff i think it's more
common than like really the numbers
would show yes i do believe that if it
was if it wasn't
a thing where someone would take it and
like make fun of you from it in a men's
perspective i think more and more men
would come forward and say something uh
no matter how great no matter no matter
what the situation is i think that
statistic would be vastly similar or
just
different well did you see the live date
that i did i had like no i wasn't able
to watch well he you know it's i brought
on um
a guy and a girl to go on a live date on
this show right and one of the questions
i asked was
have either of you ever cheated right
and he tells me this story about how
this girl like he's like passed out and
like went on top of it i was not i was
like i'm so sorry you did not have to
say that question
um and his girlfriend like broke up with
him over it
that's what yeah and i was like
that's like assault how
not like that yeah
yeah
i i had a friend that had a similar
story like that like the he was asleep
and the girl just started to do things
to him while he was sleeping he woke up
and was like
yo like what are you doing and so it's
like people and he like told his friends
he was like nah like that didn't happen
you were awake
and
it's just
yeah it's tough
you might be this is a trope that people
just accept western society is a
male-dominated patriarchy it's like no
it's not
that's not true and and even if it even
if it has a patriarchal structure to
some degree
the uh the fundamental basis of that
structure is not power it's competence
that's why our society works it's only
when as when a
structure degenerates into tyranny that
the fundamental relationships between
people become dependent on power
it's not power if you hire a plumber
who's likely to be male
it's not because there's roving bands of
tyrannical plumbers forcing you to make
that choice and it's the case with
almost every interaction that you have
at the face of our culture you're
dealing with people who are offering a
service of one form or another who are
usually part of the broad middle class
and who offer and what you're looking
for is the person who can offer the best
service and you can find it it's not a
consequence of being dominated by
anything that's tyrannical and and then
again our culture or western culture
which is by no means perfect and
certainly has tyrannical elements like
all cultures do is the least tyrannical
society that's ever been produced and
certainly the least tyrannical society
that exists now so where's the
patriarchy exactly in all of them well
saying that it's the least tyrannical
society is not the same as saying it's
not a tyrannical society that's exactly
why i said it was the least
but that's what i mean so you haven't
debunked the existence of patriarchy
then you've said that actually now is
better we don't have to debunk women
have to demonstrate its existence okay
well let's go through it i'm writing a
book about feminism in the moment uh
until 1919 there were professions that
women were barred from they simply were
not allowed to do it until 1880 why
would you blame men for that
because who was in those professions who
was guarding entry to those professions
who was worried about losing their
status if women became indoctrinated
emancipated women in the 20th century
just out of curiosity well a couple of
different things i think it was
technology i think it was the pill
helped enormously because when he was
developing the 60s right so that wasn't
1919. no but i also think it was a
series of legal changes that started in
britain with the married women's
property act which said for the first
time women are full legal beings under
the law they can own property and that
to me is a structure that has continued
throughout from a time when women didn't
have the same legal rights as men to now
when they mostly do but culture still
lags behind it i don't think you and i
are necessarily talking at such cross
purposes it's just that your conception
of patriarchy i see it in the book is
that quite a lot of men are quite nice
and they do nice things for women i know
that's not my conception of patreon and
i don't require men or advise them to be
nice
well you do talk about the guy who's the
tampon king the sanitary towel king of
india right i wouldn't call that nice
okay
brave okay did you read about his life
when he was trying to develop that yeah
god it was absolutely miserable and he
did it anyways he freed all sorts of
women as a consequence and i think that
was nice that's courageous that's noble
that's visionary it's not nice
i think it is also nice i think it is
also something that is recent you know
it is
honoring your social obligations
why is it when
men do something for women
it's like ah that's so nice of you and
they don't think of
the
the things that it took to do that and
say like like i appreciate it more and
i'm not saying all women do this but
it's like
that's nice of you because you're
supposed to be able to do something for
me like why
why is that
it's it's our society it's everything
i'm telling you once you see it you
can't unsee it like everything is just
geared towards women everything and
anytime a man does something great they
minimize it or try to say a woman did it
too
that is true
i have
i have done that before and i'm like
why a woman's done that yeah like and i
don't think it's because like people are
like i don't think you were being like
an unkind person i just think like we
like that that's we've been i hate to
say it but like brainwashed from such a
young age to like
think like this man just red pill stuff
i'm not so sure that that's a social
obligation because many other people
would have done it had it been a social
obligation
he said what he was concerned about he
saw that his wife was suffering with her
monthly period
and
had to choose between feeding her family
and taking care of herself properly and
chose to feed her family and thought he
would do something about that that goes
way past nice especially given what he
had to suffer through to do all the
experimentation that produced his his
eventual technology so like i this whole
patriarchy thing i think you have no
idea how pernicious and dangerous it is
well no i don't i really don't go
throughout history have fundamentally
cooperated to push back against the
absolute catastrophe of existence a
terrible death rate the probability of
chronic starvation early death disease
the difficulty of raising children with
all the death that was associated with
that and to look backwards in time and
say well basically what happened was men
took the upper hand and persecuted women
in this tyrannical patriarchy it's
absolutely dreadful misreading of
history it's a terrible thing to teach
young women and it's a horrible thing to
inflict upon men i mean i absolutely
disagree with you i think that's like
saying
slavery in the us was actually most
people cooperate well no you didn't you
had a system where one set of people
owned another set of people and until
women got full legal rights they could
own property themselves they could work
essentially they were owned they were
first
owned by their fathers and then by the
house of status
to the domination by men and he said
that you thought that what emancipated
women primarily in the 20th century was
technological revolution no not
primarily but that's one of two i think
there's two things primarily no i think
the pill was a primary force in the
emancipation of women i think
of tampons let's say or the or the
provision of proper sanitary uh
facilities toilets and that sort of
thing you're you're thinking instead it
was the action of courageous feminists
in the 1920s that produced a social
revolution that overthrew the patriarchy
that's your theory yeah that's a foolish
theory well i'm very sorry to hear you
say that but i think
you in the kathy newman interview i
think it's a multivariate right i think
there are lots of different things that
all contributed to well then let's not
be assuming that the western society was
a tyrannical patriarchy that's one of
them and then other things happened as
well so you have the pill you have the
dishwasher and white goods labor saving
devices in the home i think all of those
were really important but you also have
things like campaigns for the vote yes
you also have things like that yes so
how when in a system that existed in
england until 1918 went why would you
even want to look at history like that
like what what's your what's your goal
because i think the people who don't
look at history are condemned to repeat
it and i think that we we're going to
what are we going to do repeat the the
persecution of women do you think that's
a realistic possibility yeah we're
sitting here you see that we're sitting
here in america right where we've just
had a fifth judge appointed to the
supreme court who is now anti-abortion
is now conservative i think that
abortion rights are actually fundamental
to women being able to function as full
humans in society and i think that is
now under threat in america
i think it is extremely smug and
complacent to think civilization has
peaked it's all upwards from here
so to be able to
function
in this world
like nothing else to be able to function
like that that's the thing that we need
to function
abortion
that's that's the thing we need to
function that's sexist i don't like if
anything
you can't not have sex like that's the
thing we need to function like out of
everything oh my god or i don't know get
married or i don't know use like 20
million forms of birth control
abortion
that's what's going to help me build
this youtube channel that's that's oh
she that's the that's the key right
there thank you
now that i know this yeah i would
man i would be
far along in my life
yo that that's wow
the fact that she said that i'm like she
said that's the key
to women functioning
interesting is it isn't interesting i
never thought about before i mean i have
now because i watched this a couple
years ago but i never thought about
like
that it wasn't like that women were
oppressed so much it was more like men
were like taming the world almost yeah
that that's what i wanted to say i was
trying to remember it yeah
if you think about
when she said that that the girls were
owned by their fathers then essentially
owned by
their husbands
can you help me understand what she
meant by that
uh well i think it's like the feminist
world view is that like men are bad
and men did not have the best interests
of women so like for example women
couldn't vote but did you know the
majority of women didn't want to vote
yeah like if you think about way back
when
life
men were the bread winners and women
were at home so essentially the people
that are voting is affecting them if
you're at home all day raising a kid is
not really going to
affect you from my knowledge but if
you're on the work field and there's
laws that are putting being put in place
that affect you in the workforce just in
life in general that you are in 24 7
then you have a say in it but if it
doesn't affect you and i never thought
about that until now i was like huh well
and uh it came with the draft so that's
why we didn't want to vote because like
then you would have to be drafted
yeah and i kind of want to return our
rights
i don't want to have the opportunity to
be drafted thanks
no no no i want to return all of our
rights i want to go back to the kitchen
you see i keep driving let's give it
back
pearl needs a driver if anybody is a
driver out there
anyone want to let me i don't really
like cleaning though i'll be a poor
housewife
a poor housewife like a bad one
she'll do the bare minimum if you're
looking for a bare minimum housewife
do you know what they didn't think about
everything's automated nowadays if we
just stuck it out
now we're back then they had to hand
wash the lawn
been horrible i'd have been like no i'm
not doing this you know what i'm saying
though like if we just waited another 50
years everything would have been
automated housewife so much easier yep
housewives would have been gucci i
probably would not be in school if
if they didn't have women's rights i'd
probably be at home with what are we
doing
why
what that's right why are we here
i'm grateful i'm grateful to be here
sort of
i'm grateful i wouldn't be in student
debt though that would be debt-free
grateful
yeah well
um
good luck with that
it's a living like you know i there are
lots of people who agree with me there
are lots of people clearly who agree
with you
um i want to know they're just a lot of
people i would say
who are coming to listen to what i say
because they're sick and tired of having
their desire to move forward in the
world and to achieve something and to
take their place as adult males let's
say
who are under the weight of accusations
that their ambition and forthrightness
is a manifestation of something that's
fundamentally tyrannical they're not
happy with that it's not doing anyone
any good and it's also not true it's
really a terrible thing to do to young
men and it's happening all the time
that's why they're bailing out of
universities like mad there will be a
man left in the social sciences in 10
years in the universities and it's no
bloody wonder it's an unhospitable place
and it's unhospitable precisely because
of this doctrine said that throughout
history the fundamental relationship
between men and women was one of power
essentially slavery it's like fine
believe it if you want it's not going to
do your relationships any good i can
tell you that
so okay well we'll we'll see how that
one goes i'm currently married but you
know i'll i'll raise it with him wait i
wonder if she still is i was i wonder
let me know in the comments if she still
is yes
um i think the university's example is a
really fascinating one because you talk
in the book about the fact that now
women are a majority on two-thirds of
college courses in the us uh and you
know i've also seen you saying would you
believe in equality of opportunity but
not a qualitative outcome
maybe
that i don't believe in equality of
outcome i think it's an unbelievably
pathological wish and doctrine right but
very dangerous history has demonstrated
exactly how dangerous it is equality of
opportunity is something that anyone
with any sense would support but
equality of outcome it's
so what's your problem with enough
beyond belief to to to support equality
of outcomes okay so what's your problem
with there not being enough men in the
social sciences perhaps women are just
cleverer perhaps that's why there are
more women at university right under
your doctrine i don't think that but
that's why i think the logical extent of
your doctor isn't the fact that there's
an unequal distribution the problem i
have with it is that the reason that men
are bailing out is because of the
prevalence of the doctrine that you're
espousing that's the problem i have with
it it doesn't matter that much they will
bail out i don't see any way that the
universities are going to redeem
themselves in the next decade
so and and maybe that will be fine but i
doubt it
let's see that seems extremely
pessimistic when the majority the
numbers of people going to university
just generally are going up yeah well
that's not going to last for very long
why not because it's too expensive and
the universities are doing all sorts of
things that aren't
acceptable mostly racking up the price
ratcheting up the price
so and and decreasing the quality of
what they're offering and playing into
the hands of the people who are
ideological acolytes of the identity
politics routines and playing
post-modern stunts and pushing
neo-marxism and all these things that
are characteristic of of the social
sciences and the humanities primarily
see this is where i find you you
fascinating to me because
you know you talk in these quite
apocalyptic terms i think that you know
someone will listen to that and think
wow there's a really big problem but
what we're really talking about is
some irritatingly postmodern professors
and some students with blue hair and
funny ideas about gender in a handful of
courses around america if that's what we
were talking about no one would have
paid attention to me for more than about
15 minutes
so you might see this is some surface
manifestation that's irrelevant but that
isn't how most people view it oh
certainly the case too that this
identity politics battle of ideas
was a determining factor in the last
american election if hillary wouldn't
have played identity politics played
cozy with the identity politics type she
would have kept the working class and
she would be president now so these
aren't trivial issues by any stretch of
the imagination it's not just some kids
having a decent time while they're being
creatively rebellious at university it's
a much deeper problem than that the
doctrine the doctrines that i'm
opposed to
are predicated on well one assumption
they're predicated on it's probably the
primary assumption is that the best way
to view history is as the domination of
a tyrannical male patriarchy and that's
true also particularly of the west which
is a doctrine i find absolutely
unpalatable and historically absurd
biologically ridiculous and ungrateful
among other things
who's ungrateful sorry in that who is
being ungrateful
look at what you have right you live in
the best society that's ever been
created you know i was reading about
some indians do you mean me as a woman
or me as a 21st century person in in the
world i mean us yeah i mean i'm
incredibly grateful what i have but to
me the project of politics it's
construction of a tyrannical patriarchy
you're grateful for the productions of a
tyrannical patriarchy how does that make
sense because i think life is good i
think it could be better
that that's that's being a progressive
reasonable proposition but i guess that
isn't commensurate with your claim that
you're the beneficiary of the tyrannical
patriarchy why not
how can it be good if it's the
consequence of a tyrannical patriarchy
tyranny isn't good is it i mean that's
the definition of tyranny something that
isn't good and yet it's produced all
these things that you're grateful for
like
doesn't that contradict in contradiction
bother you where did where did what was
good come from
where is well i think from i think i'm
benefiting actually from a lot of things
that i don't support that are unearned
privileges in my life i think that's
absolutely true it's your job like i
have a very good job i had a loving
family
who well i don't think that's going to
do the world any good is it that's a
hell of a fine rationalization for your
privileged position oh well fair enough
but like you know if you could trade it
off with someone who's less privileged i
could be a start i could i could do that
and and
but i don't i don't want to and i won't
and i don't think i should be expected
to why not is it okay for you to occupy
a position of privilege in the
patriarchal tyranny and if it is is it
because you're female or is it just
because it's convenient let me tell you
my political philosophy i'm i guess i'm
a social democrat so what i believe is
that you should if you have a good life
you should try and pass that on i
believe in a progressive redistributive
tax system for example
it was once said by lord mandelson in
british politics you know but new labour
was okay with people being filthy rich
as long as they paid their taxes now i'm
kind of less okay with people being
filthy rich
well that i think i would leave that
you're probably in the top one tenth of
one percent of people who've ever lived
on the planet that would constitute
filthy rich by historical standards okay
but i'm not sure where that is in the
line exactly be able to help the
neanderthals at this point really by
giving up some money but this is my
point is that what i believe is i
believe in a structure in which people
who have had a good life and had lots of
advantages should pay that back pay that
forwards which i think is the message
that you preach as well right you have
responsibilities and if you've had like
us
a lot of advantages civilization has a
tyrannical patriarchy it's not purely a
tyrannical fact that's for sure it isn't
it's purely not right that's exactly the
issue but why would you describe it as a
tyrannical patriarchy then you make a
case that it's purely that and that's
exactly what's ungrateful it's not
purely that at all why are you saying
that something has elements of this made
the same as it is purely that isn't
what's being said merely to define it as
a patriarch implies unit unit unit
dimensionality and to insist that that's
also tyrannical doesn't offer a balanced
viewpoint at all well i think that's
probably where yeah i think that's
probably where your disagreement comes
with this which is because i do not see
it in that way i do not see that is
univariate at all i see it as one might
call it a patriarchy because it
describes an overarching structure does
it and what if the patriarch is
fundamentally composed of women is it
still patriarchy that would be a
matriarchy would it so let's say we take
a patriarchal structure like the medical
profession and we fill it primarily with
women is it then a matriarchal structure
what makes it a patriarch to begin with
is it the hierarchical structures that
is it the fact that it's mostly men is
it the sociological structure or is it
the fact that it's mostly men well i
think that's really interesting because
male primary school teachers for example
only 15 of them are men and i
interviewed some of them for my book and
you know what they report exactly the
same things that women do in male
dominated offices right they say people
have conversations that i feel excluded
from i feel stigmatized like i shouldn't
be here people look at me as scants when
i say i'm a primary school teacher and
i'm a man you know they kind of reel
back we all make those implicit
associations so so if it is if it is a
structure that's dominated by women then
it's also a tyrannical patriarchy i
think in that case then men have a way
of they should be able to complain about
the fact that a very female dominated
office leaves them feeling out too yeah
i'm really feeling left out so how do we
get something that isn't a tyrannical
patriarchy if it's composed of women and
it's a tyrannical patriarchy and if it's
composed of men it's a tyrannical
patriarchy we're kind of out of options
right but well or you could have a blend
an office in which a blend of people of
both so if it's 50 50 then it's not a
tyrannical picture no not 50 50. i'm
saying that 40 60. i'm saying that there
is clearly when there's only 15 percent
of male parameters which is they do feel
marginalized and excluded so so you
think the defining hallmark of a
tyrannical social structure is the
predominance of one gender and if that
was if that was relatively equalized
then all of a sudden it would be a free
and an open institution i don't think
that the male primary teachers being
tyrannized i do think they are being
marginalized and i do think that they
feel excluded and stressed
well this is what i mean i think
actually and i'm i'm surprised you don't
agree with me on this that actually
having more male primary school teachers
would be a really good thing because
boys need role models actually
particularly boys who don't have a
father figure in their life that's
really important to have a stable adult
who shows them what it's like to be a
man around the place could be but you
shouldn't achieve it as a consequence of
preferential hiring
no i don't need necessarily need to be
preferential hiring i think it would
neces it would probably be about making
that job breaking down the stigma to
entering that job i think teaching is a
really interesting example it was seen
at the time when i was 18 19 right there
were no men in it and how did
so
the point he made about
so
if
if it was 50 50 it would be uh all good
i'm i'm expecting her to be like yeah of
course like if it was 50 50 the world
would be great she was like no i was
like well then what what do you what are
you arguing like do you want it to be
more women-led or do you want to be more
male that like what what is it that you
want because right now what you're
saying
is it it's like you don't know what you
want in the world and it's just like
it's and and the one thing i don't like
is she's saying that you should hire
people just based on their gender
yeah
like it should be the most qualified
person for the job if that's men or
women and it turns out to be 90 women or
90 men then so be it yeah but like i'm
really like how do you feel about quotas
i i think
in
i'm laughing because someone in the
comments said yes i think sorry i say it
a lot but um
for me i would say that in some
circumstances that a quota
is
necessary okay um
just so for representation purposes okay
um
don't you think it's a little like um
sexist or racist
because because it's like almost saying
that these like like if i'm a woman i
can't get the job myself i need the
government to tell them to do it yeah
like and i i think it actually hurts the
people because then people just start to
think you got there because of a quota
rather than your competence yeah
you make a good point you make a good
point and it's okay if you disagree this
is just how i feel oh no yeah
okay
it's hard because
yes
a quota would just be like oh i just
hired you because you we needed to meet
a quota and that's all and they didn't
look at your
your um
jobs that you've had before and
everything and your qualifications they
just look like oh you're this we we need
to check this block me and check this
box this person does it we'll
train them and so in that in those type
of cases yes it's
it is like
not good it's harmful not harmful but it
does hurt the
the person and it's just like they they
didn't get the job because they were
qualified they got the job because of
something
that they needed a quote that they
needed and you know it's really hurting
like minority communities and education
because um colleges like that's what
they do but the problem is like it makes
smart kids fail because they're at the
wrong university
so no it's like thomas sowell has a
whole book on like the decline in dogma
of education that's what they're talking
about in there too
and like because like let's say me okay
i i'm i'm i'm decently smart okay i'm
good at school but i'm not smart enough
to get into say um michigan like i think
that was like a pretty smart or let's
say okay yeah and if they let me in i
would leave thinking i was stupid
because i could not compete okay so if i
i got like a 23 24 and i know you guys
have
sats we have a cts oh and we're where i
went to school uh we have the sats and
ac okay so you you know we're at 23 24.
yeah that doesn't i'm above average yeah
that doesn't make me like like dumb but
like i would feel dumb at the wrong
school
so if they're going off of like what you
look like it almost hurts you later
because you're not qualified yeah and
and they show that because like um
like the kids with the lower ac2 scores
drop out at a higher rate or they switch
their major
even though like they could have done
that fine if they went to like i went to
school right yeah
wow
and so it's almost like and it's funny
because the people that pat themselves
on the back and they're saying i'm
fighting for these people i'm doing a
good job they're hurting them
yeah wow
i never thought about it isn't that
interesting yeah because then you have
yes representation matters but
representation in the i would say in the
right way matters when you know like
you're supposed to when you're when you
go to the areas you're qualified that
will help you
best because if you're
if you're in an area where say i know
nothing about tech but i applied for
like a tech job and they just needed i
heard they just needed a young black
female to be to work there and i got in
there it wouldn't benefit me at all
because i'm not qualified but i'm
qualified for their quota and you would
you would feel dumb even though even
though you're not because you're at the
wrong place
like have you ever been in a room and
you just feel like oh plenty of time so
i i can't count
so many times
i should not be here right but it's
because it's not because like like i've
been in places where i'm the dumbest one
in the room and
it's not like
it's helpful at times but you don't want
to feel like you can't compete at all
yeah you don't want to feel like you
can't
interact with the conversation
it'd be like if the lions the london
lions took me on their team because they
needed a
we need a tall ginger all right they
would eff me up
and i wouldn't improve at all because i
would just get my like get rocked every
day
those girls are killed guys the london
lions is like a basketball team yeah
wbbo
so they're like one of the top good one
of the best teams in europe right now so
yeah that that makes sense yeah what do
you think okay one more question what do
you think about what he said about
education
um what was your major uh physical
education
like pe yeah oh i didn't know that was
like a major i thought it was just
education um
the school i went to it was separated
and then anything like physical activity
that has to do with the body is now
underneath kinesiology and so that's why
it wasn't just education it was more
science
a little bit yeah so i don't know if you
had the same experience as me
but i felt like the colleges are very
left
and like they very much pushed like at
my school they would push like
like trans stuff like my school was
really known and like they wanted like
it was like known for bringing trans
people in the dorms and it was like very
much like the left and feminist ideology
was in all the classrooms and like
i i felt like it was very much pushed on
us
did you feel the same or no no because
the school i went to was a christian
school so
we had
the first year i was there there was a
teacher
that
i think they were trans and it like blew
up that
they didn't you were the opposite yeah
the complete opposite and it blew up to
where um
that person was released or wasn't able
to work there because of that because of
the beliefs that the school had
and then there were some
gay students that came to the school or
students that just didn't believe in
what the school believed in and they
like went at the um
the head people and just told them like
this is wrong you should welcome
everybody
and so yeah it was a complete opposite
do you think a school has a right to
have its beliefs about that stuff
i think if
dang it
if
if a school
it's hard because if if i
if i wasn't who i am and i went to a
school that didn't
technically accept me but that's like
the best school for me and that's where
i think i would excel the most i should
have the right to be able to go to that
school no matter who i am or what i
believe but it's hard when a school is
based on like that's their foundation on
what they believe and they have it like
your school had like feminism and trans
stuff that's like in the classrooms and
taught that's how it was for us and uh
almost every class or we had to take
bible classes and we had to do an
exegetical i haven't never heard of a
college doing that yes and we had there
was i write the name of it
as is am i allowed to say it um if you
want that's mine azusa pacific
university i don't have never heard of
it yeah um it's in azusa california but
um in california yeah
yeah and so um we had to do in every
class it was
a paper where what we were learning how
do we connect it to scripture how we use
it with that so we had that in the
classes and it was it was difficult for
students who either were catholic or
atheist or
just a different religion or didn't
believe in anything
and
they were like well why do we have to do
this i don't believe in it and
it's hard because that school was based
on that but also like they had great
programs that different people came
there for and it's like why should i be
denied access to a great program that i
think i will excel at because i don't
believe the same thing i just feel like
if if the the school i feel like the
school has a right to market to who they
want to market to and that just wasn't
who they were marketing yeah just like
my school like i didn't try to make them
not trans
right i just i just minded my business
yeah exactly but i said that would they
not let you in if you were gay or was it
just like if you were publicly like
i don't i don't know if they didn't let
people i know they they let them in
um
it was just it's hard when
yeah
it you have to go to chapel three times
a week and you had to go to chapel one
three times a week and if we missed
10 or more chapels throughout the
semester we had to we
either got fined or had to like write a
paper or something we had very different
colleges yes
yes
yeah
so because i went to a small school and
it technically was affiliated with some
church but it was not like okay it
wasn't it wasn't like a party school
either it was kind of in between i would
say but like
no
it was definitely like left yeah and we
were completely on the other side